it's five standard invite gheymeh game
one of how many i do not know I do not
know how many games will be played but I
do know this this is Game one I also
know that my fan is going crazy because
I am running on a laptop so let's roll
here we have a Queens gambit declined
and we might be entering what does
anybody recalling the Carlson vs.
Kasparov game where Carlson ended up
drawing when he was a very young kid
there what do we do here um c 6 of
course the center allows for Queen a 5
i'm drawing a blank here Bishop d3
Knight f3 does it really matter let's
get my night out why not get that night
out of there off of that back rank what
if the Queen comes here no well it's not
going there so don't worry about it
let's go bishop I thought I might be
having to do like a night d to move
which is not something you really want
to do out of the opening pretty atypical
to move the same piece more than once in
the opening something you really
shouldn't be doing but there may have
been a purpose to do just that let's
challenge is bishop i'm i'm not going to
castle and hold off on that because of
what because i might be wanting to do
what I might be wanting to have black
capture have me recaptured towards the
center by default unless there's a good
reason to do otherwise and then have a
half-open H file to be playing with now
with this move i'm still I guess making
black thing to themselves is white going
to Castle kingside or queenside see the
difference between just running with an
immediate castle and making a a purpose
will move off the back rank focusing
indirectly on e4 which is a square that
black could be making use of with this
night could easily see the RIP playing
to this file here it is half open
logical deployment of the rook I'm I
think I might be interested in queenside
castles I give that a shot and I really
do not plan on keeping my king on c1 for
too long I think black was a bit
concerned about a potential night b5
move although I don't think it would
turn out to be so great because there
would seem to always be a queen a5 check
for as long as my king is on e 1 of
course so well here we go the C file is
ready to be blown right open and if I
don't capture it see force plate hits my
bishop then be 5 b-4 with tempo I don't
know if I like that I also don't know if
I like pawn takes Knight takes hitting
my bishop something is a little bit
scary without
we're about even on time what I do do I
really want to deal with a three to two
majority because if I don't react
correctly that's exactly what we could
have on this side of the board three
verses to take Knight takes bishop here
the light squared Bishop scum off I
think I'm helping black develop by doing
that I'm going to take and then throw my
king on b1 because right now if you ask
him if he's comfortable on c1 his answer
is definitely not definitely not and
I'll pre-move that in case there's that
capture if Knight takes I go here if
Knight takes bishop Queen takes if
something sneaky like g6 is played
preparing Bishop f5 I'm going to throw
my king in the corner I think a one will
be even safer than v1 let's go right
away if Knight takes Queen takes or if
no Knight takes let's say something like
g6 is played immediately I still want to
throw my king right here okay here we go
i have no light square Bishop i better
be very cautious of wherever it is this
bishop may want to be going if it gets
to have five that is TKO land now this
pond has hit three times defended once
but the Queen does not act well as a
leader and I may not even be needing to
move my king away if I because I could
rely upon my night to be on d4 can I not
or can't I quit getting fancy 92
blockade blockade that isolated pawn
that's the plan
ah
now what less than two minutes for my
good opponent who continues to give me
good games we have played more than one
said that right from the start I think
one of the games that we played I had
posted to my youtube channel I don't
know if I want to just stick around on
each one with this rook I really i'm not
seeing so much happen on the H file so i
might want to transfer my attention i
was just going to say Brooksie one and
the other up to d1 now with this if I
take the Queen then there is no longer
you know the possibility for let's say
me to exploit this pawn right here now
what is being threatened his Queen takes
rook takes Bishop here no it's not I
lied the Knights there to watch over
rook here do not do that because you
like your queen too much I'm struggling
to UM relay my candidate moves to you
the viewer here because I don't really
have very many capture the Queen move my
kingdom corner b3 is a little bit weird
a little bit weakening f3 to just stop
night moves let me give that a shot why
not we're about even with the time I
spent quite a bit of time on that last
move if the Queen's do come off you'll
notice after the exchange I am one step
closer to being able to form a battery
along that d file and you know I'm
seeing now since I have this f3 move
played initially my thoughts were ok
just watch over a knight move here or g4
but since it's a here right now I'm
already considering let's say g4 I could
view it as both the preventive and
facilitating g4 g5 stuff so here we go
the ladies are off g4 is here maybe
still this is a possibility I have
control over this dark
Square and I will be getting kicked away
very soon night here that can definitely
be a little bit annoying now what do you
do I take this recapture I'm not getting
at that pond so I think this is a good
move now you'll notice i was a bit
reluctant to run with it earlier when
the queens are still on the board and
the primary reason why I'm doing it now
is for to read for two things one watch
over sea for because I was fearful of
nike5 to see four and two I guess I
could be bumping my camp to be to an
ideal square being that it's on a dark
square opposite that of this bishop and
I guess just one step closer to being in
the center of the board which is exactly
where you want that King in the end game
so now i'm pretty sure i could be
getting this pawn so let me let my
brooks see this pond directly and now it
could be one my only question now is
should i take it right away or just
throw an additional piece on it maybe
not here is just best if I hit a fourth
time it's still defended twice there's
nothing nothing that could really be
done let me let me go here so it's hit
four times three directly one indirectly
and let's go with this one I could
always support it with this I am I guess
I am in a little bit of a pin that's
uncomfortable but let's let's get out of
this and I don't want to get into just a
night ending so that's why I chose to
not go with the rook capture at that
point and now let's get some more I
didn't need a three actually let's do
this what's the time situation we do
this if the King up clock
king and pawn in game is this winning is
it winning Oh fast pond push the King
away can't take otherwise run he runs
fast okay he's flying there's no time
though okay as usual a flurry of moves
right there towards the end in time
pressure for both of us and as usual
another good game by mr. sock hall all
right let me hit the rewind button on
this and flip the board and look at
things from my opponents perspective and
maybe we can take a thing or two away
from this so Queen pond opening if
you're interested in knowing a bit more
about the difference between Knight f6
and Bishop to e7 at this point a recent
YouTube video i posted explains it in
more detail that video is if you
searched for Geary vs. Aronian I think
could be one of the first few that would
populate in that search result so okay
and it has a thumbnail of both about
both of those players as well so okay we
have this and it's when I saw the night
d7 move this is entering a what's like a
Cambridge spring defense but we don't
have the typical Queen a5 move but this
seems to be quite alright I think well I
wonder if the Queen's move is the right
thing to be running with maybe maybe
there's even a better a better setup
here the night out I take you take i
geti 6c six maybe queen 85 with Bishop
here in 94 the typical Cambridge Springs
idea is maybe what black should be
running with because I wonder if it's
now
turning out to be a bit of a drawback to
have this night deployed to the d7
square before having developed the light
square Bishop so I'm wondering if you
are going to do this maybe it is best to
follow through with the pressure on this
diagonal and maybe force an eventual
retreat type of move with 92 just
something that you would find in the
Cambridge Springs defense on the white
end this is a move that does show up and
in that are no wait you know I was
mistaken by the way I made a video on it
it was not a aronian vert it was not
Geary versus aronian excuse me it was
Carlson versus Kasparov and it was the
last game analysis video that I i posted
on the channel so anyhow sorry about
that so anyhow I think I think the Queen
a5 with Bishop before is going to be the
way to go because now I'm feeling pretty
comfortable I think this is blacks best
try but it comes at a drawback of having
this pond isolate and this can't be too
comfortable so I think that's my main
suggestion may be going in a different
direction with the Queen and dark
squared Bishop placement maybe just gone
putting pressure on that diagonal
because I don't know even though you
have the bishop hair I have firm control
over this isolated pond I don't know if
there's really an attack against the
king so maybe even hear it too may be
the best resistance is to just play b5
and not take the Queen B 5 b-4 stuff
maybe not i'm not quite sure but anyhow
okay let me close out